police in washington dc are beefing up
beefing up security to prepare for
potential violence at a far-right rally
the organization look ahead america has
called on right-wing and extremist
groups to take to the streets it wants
to show support for those arrested or
charged in connection with the january 6
attack on the u.s capitol building with
the memory of that day's riot still
fresh law enforcement does not does not
want to be caught off guard again
this is normally as exciting as it gets
around the reflecting pool at the foot
of the capitol building a family of male
ducks on a cross pond swim people
strolling along the washington mall or
shadow boxing but these days there are
significantly more police than there
used to be
so here we are this is it this is union
square
right at the reflection pond in front of
the capital and this is where the
protesters are expected together on
saturday 700
says the organizer of the protest by the
way the organizer of the protest is a
former trump campaign operative and he
said he assures law enforcement that
nobody
will be bringing any weapons that
everything will be peaceful
given recent experiences with pro-trump
supporters and rallies in washington law
enforcement agencies are not taking the
organizer's word for it on january 6
there was no fence around capitol hill
that was when rioters attacked and
intruded into this house of democracy
now the fence is back protecting capitol
hill and capitol hill police as well as
the metropolitan police in washington dc
say they are well prepared for whatever
might come
the capital will be closed for business
and completely deserted on the day of
the protest the national guard has been
asked to be on standby
not only have capitol police and d.c
metropolitan police activated their
entire forces for the next day or two
agents here at the fbi are also involved
in looking at the threat scenario this
protest may be posed for the capital for
washington d.c
the latest intelligence suggests that
extremist right-wing groups like the
proud boys or the oath keepers will not
come to washington online chatter has
labeled the protest as an fbi trap or a
so-called false flag event however
there's still concern and here's why
freedom plaza
the site of many pro-trump support
protests in the past and before january
6.
now
this place here will be the site of a
counter protest for what will happen at
the capitol just up the street and that
is a concern for police
speaking of concerns
we'll see what happens
well if if there's this much advance
notice hopefully there'll be more
preparation you know this police force
is terrific so i'm sure they'll if
there's a weakness they'll strengthen it
not good for our city
i'll just say that
hoping for a peaceful event and being
prepared for the opposite it will after
all be a pro-trump rally in support of
january 6 rioters and directions
you